big news weekend very exciting Jen briny
from congressional dish podcast is
joining me in studio we'll be talking to
Jen more about her show on the bonus
show and a little bit later today but
she will be filling in for me tomorrow
it'll be a travelled a very very long
travel day I might have picked the most
inefficient flight itinerary to get to
Las Vegas and the reasons why would bore
everybody in here especially Pat so I'm
gonna I'm gonna skip that story and well
how many times only one stop holding on
stop but eight and a half hours of
flying to get to Las Vegas from Boston
and it's it's not gonna be good for
anybody but plenty of time to use
mediocre American Airlines Wi-Fi and to
do work okay I like talking about double
standards and double standards exist for
example when we see the same statistics
either believed or not believed
depending on who's in office and who
those statistics are good for and one
really good example is gas prices I'm
sure you remember when gas prices went
up under george w bush republicans would
say well you know the president only has
limited influence over what gas prices
do and then when gas prices went back
down under george w bush then george w
bush had done a really amazing thing by
pushing gas prices down and then when
they were up under obama the same people
who said the president doesn't really
influence gas prices were blaming obama
and then of course when gas prices came
back down under obama you heard
no-nothing effectively from republicans
crediting him and the reality is usually
more nuanced that's not one or the other
it's well presidential fought policy
sort of creates the context in which gas
prices could go up or could go down but
it's not really the president themselves
that's influencing it and for me one of
the biggest double standards around
statistics has been jobs right george w
bush governed over a disastrous economy
under obama we saw a big jobs recovery
millions of jobs created unemployment
went down and republicans sort of were
not really willing to accept this they
popularized the labor participation rate
conspiracy theories i don't know if
that's something you've talked about
I've covered that extensively widely
debunked they've called the CBO data
fake and completely not believable and
the truth is that if we look into the
economic situation we see that listen
the
resident of course has some to do with
jobs numbers but there's broader
economic circumstances Bush had a bad
economy and a terrible stock market
partially because of 9/11 we could
debate how much he was directly
responsible for 9/11 needless to say the
2008 recession which came as a result of
the mortgage crisis and the credit
crisis certainly deregulation in general
impacted that but it wasn't george w
bush specifically who did all of that
deregulation and there's no doubt that
under the obama presidency we were due
for somewhat of a recovery but the
stimulus and some other Obama policies
probably helped but that's where we get
to our current president Donald Trump
and the recent jobs numbers which are
not the best jobs numbers only about a
hundred and four thousand jobs created
in March which was almost half of the
nearly two hundred thousand jobs that
economists expected to see created and
these are the same numbers gen that
under President Obama Donald Trump said
were fake numbers and not believable
early in Trump's presidency when the
numbers were still looking pretty good
all of a sudden they were bragging
rights for Donald Trump about how good
the economy was and then now all of a
sudden that his jobs numbers are falling
short of expectations we hear nothing
about the jobs numbers at all do you
think that the average trumpet even
cares about this like dude does it even
matter to them what's going on with the
jobs numbers or is it really all
narrative for them I think it's all
narrative I mean I don't even think that
they're aware of this report to be
honest it's whether or not they have a
job and so yeah I don't know a ton of
Trump voters either there is also that I
live in California but um the few that I
do know they're more concerned with
their own health insurance in their own
little worlds and they just like the guy
I mean I think it just comes down to
that he's the straight talker or
whatever I don't know I don't think that
these are the type of people that are
looking at jobs reports because if they
were they probably wouldn't be voting
for John Donald Trump the the most
depressing thing to me is that job
creation over several years really
hasn't changed
in other words when you adjust down so
the January and February numbers that we
initially got that were initially
reported were actually revised in the
downward direction and they were
actually 50,000 fewer jobs created in
January and February and when you really
look over the long term including the
last few years job creation has been
relatively stable across the last few
years of Obama and Donald Trump and for
me the real disappointing part is that
it would be great if we could sort of
get beyond the politicization of any one
month and sort of look at the broader
trends and the realization that number
one if you didn't believe the numbers
under obama and you believe them under
trump but when they're good or not
that's a double standard that's
hypocrisy and that should really concern
all of us but the broader concern for me
is that number one the job creation wave
that's been touted by the current
administration doesn't really exist
we're really very very close to them to
mean job creation but most importantly
nobody's doing anything to solve the
impending job crisis and wigs
wage stagnation that we've had right
technological unemployment is coming we
don't really have any plan to deal with
it and as I've talked about before
presidential candidates don't want to
talk about that because whoever flinches
first and says hold on a second Trump
says he's gonna bring back jobs from
China a lot of those jobs don't exist
they've been replaced by machines as
soon as one candidate says that the
other will say that's a defeatist
attitude and that certainly doesn't
sound like you're gonna fix the problem
even though the truth is neither party
is actually dealing with that and I feel
like both Democrats and Republicans are
basically given a pass on that issue I
think that's true and I think we also
have a problem where we blame and give
credit to the president for things that
the president like you said before
doesn't really have any control over so
when we're talking about something like
creating jobs and really deciding how
the economy functions so much of that is
done by Congress through legislation
with tax credits and and who it gets
advantages and who doesn't and it's also
to the Justice Department like when you
think about the end of the Bush years
the Justice Department wasn't going
after white-collar criminals and that's
really what crashed the economy it was
this mortgage crisis where there was
just fraud everywhere and and then in
the Obama administration to be fair they
didn't prosecute it either so this stuff
is still happening and I think that type
of thing
allowing corporate crimes in allowing
massive layoffs and just allowing the
stuff to go on a lot of it isn't with
the President himself there's other
parts of our government that are acting
that are being ignored and of course
this isn't to say it doesn't matter
who's president right because of course
what we have is a situation where when
one party does control all three
branches rather the House Senate and the
White House that provides significant
political cover so just because we can't
point to a specific action or Anika nama
CRA's alt and say here's what the
President did that caused it there's no
question that when you have everybody on
the same page you do have political
cover and nobody is really going to go
out of their way to say hey the people
in my party are actually exacerbating
this even if it is the house or the
Senate and not the president that's
doing it I think there's also a case to
be made that there were so many jobs
made under Obama that there are just
fewer to go around now like the
unemployment rates you look at over 4%
you know Trump can't really keep that
job creation going and he could make
that argument that there just aren't as
many jobs to go around now but it
doesn't really fit in with his style
that's not that's not the braggadocio or
used to it Trump that's an example of
the sort of realism that there it's a
no-win for anybody to bring that up as I
mentioned before like when when Mitt
Romney was running against President
Obama in 2012 and he was going to he was
making economic predictions about what
would be going on he made some that were
crazy like every college graduate will
have a job of course that's not true
it's an impossible promise but it was
pretty clear to the extent that we can
even make economic predictions and our
ability to do that is admittedly
somewhat limited it was pretty clear
that the second term of Obama or the
first term of Romney was going to
generally be a pretty good economic
period of four years could have varied
of course depending on whether it was
Romney and Obama whatever Romney tax
cuts for the rich would have been put in
place probably would would not have done
much to stimulate the economy but to
some degree like there are economic
cycles and it's it would be refreshing
to hear that sometimes that's true and
that's why people support the david
pakman show to the extent that they do I
think that's a good thing if we're so so
to get back to my main point what we
really need is sort of some
comprehensive way of a
Society saying hey a lot of jobs are
going to continue disappearing
technology is getting rid of a lot of
jobs we continue to see increased
productivity from people who are working
but they're not getting those wages
those wages are actually going to
stockholders and to the owners of the
company and that's really the problem
that needs to be dealt with and it's
just not being dealt with and we're not
going to see it dealt with when we have
four-year presidential cycles members of
the House of Representatives with
two-year terms who go directly back into
campaigning what's the incentive right
there's just no incentive and you cover
this in the house in the House and
Senate in particular what could be
changed to actually create an incentive
to deal with the long-term problems when
you've just got to raise money to be
re-elected another 18 months from now I
just don't see it yeah exactly and I
think there's also when we're talking
about jobs in particular we also have to
keep in mind that when they're counting
jobs are those jobs part-time are they
paying $7 an hour or are they actually
helping the economy because what you
need are people that have money to spend
right you need people that are able to
go to restaurants you need people that
are able to go and go shopping but if
you're getting paid $7 an hour and you
live in let's say Northern California
where you can't even live anywhere near
your job your money goes to
transportation it all goes to rent you
have nothing left over yeah you can look
at the jobs report all day but if it's
those types of jobs that are being
created we're not really helping the
economy or our society as a whole I've
expressed as Pat knows some concerns
about how universal basic income is
being touted and I think it's a great
idea and in fact I think we're going to
need something like it but I don't know
if you've been following how Mark
Zuckerberg and Jeff Bezos and a lot of
these effectively de facto oligarchs of
major American industry are really in
favor of it and my concern is that if we
figure out we're going to give people
nine thousand dollars or twelve thousand
dollars or sixteen thousand dollars or
whatever you're going to not fix a lot
of the systemic problems that exist in
terms of the inequality in corporate vs.
employee negotiating power we have
almost no union representation in the
country it's not going to address the
fact that health care costs are out of
control and many people still don't have
access I want universal basic income or
something like it to the extent that it
will actually fix some of the
problems you're describing but I want to
be sure that it's not just going to be a
way to give people another 10 grand 9 of
which will be spent on Amazon stuff that
people don't really need type of thing
and I don't know how you deal with that
well I mean instead of maybe universal
basic income maybe Universal housing you
know so you just have a small apartment
that you would get we can call them the
projects we can call them whatever but
just to give people basic shelter
because coming from Northern California
I can tell you that we have humans
living all over the place in the streets
and under freeways and and so I just
think when you think what humans need
their basic needs food shelter water if
we can take care of that then the cash
can take care of itself but like you
said like let's say you're getting
$10,000 I don't know even a $10,000 what
I don't know the numbers when people are
talking about universal basic income
that's a factor too I don't know how
much we're talking about two general
ideas one is ubi by itself provides a
living wage as defined by what is
necessary for usually the idea is a one
or a two bedroom apartment plus
reasonable food cost like it really
covers all basic expenses those are the
sort of more ambitious proposals the
other idea is what if everybody just
gets 10 grand added on whether you're
working or not it's not means-tested if
you're super rich you get the 10 grand
if you're if you make no money you get
10 grand and the idea is that by
eliminating all the bureaucracy of
individualized welfare programs you just
save money over the long term by giving
everybody 10 grand but the thing is
that's not a living wage and that's
absolutely concern about it well in it
maybe it is in Central Oklahoma but in
the Bay Area
10 grand isn't going to do anything and
that's where we have so many people
living under freeways yeah so I do like
the idea of providing the things people
need providing these small apartments
and being like listen if you want to
live in this dinky little place that's
not great but it's provided by the
government forever like you go right
ahead and that can be a safety net that
applies to all of us yeah but the rich
people aren't going to take advantage of
that because they don't need the dinky
apartment they have a match and a lot of
people on the right will say well you're
encouraging laziness you're encouraging
people to just live in the quote little
dinky apartment you're always going to
have Free Riders in
system there's a sort of social
insurance system the question is does
society as a whole benefit from reducing
the number of homeless people and if the
answer is yes
what do you care that someone's choosing
to live on ten grand a year if that's
what they want to do we just shouldn't
really be concerned about that is my
view yeah I'm a hundred percent fine
with that because I mean as a woman who
walks alone in the Bay Area all the time
I would like to be able to walk under a
freeway underpass without fearing for my
life there are all sorts of ancillary
benefits and also negative externalities
sort of to be considered here and to
make it politically valuable to I don't
know if you can get there by just
raising taxes on the rich I think it
would have to come from eliminating that
bureaucracy that we see in our social
welfare programs yeah so maybe starting
to eliminate unemployment benefits or
you know like handouts so we call them
and make that into universal basic
income that's probably the best way
forward it's actually fiscally
conservative to do that to consolidate a
lot of these programs eliminate the huge
apparatus of staffing that is there to
determine whether you do or don't
qualify again the concern with what Pat
is saying which I agree with is in the
net you might end up actually not having
people with more resources and then
you're not even really moving from the
the circum to the status quo that we
have today but sort of a different
conversation for ubi maybe for some
other point send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman are you on Twitter
what is that what's your Twitter handle
at Jen brainy Jen Brian II okay very
good we'll take a break and be back with
more after this the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership